the body keeps the score is the
beautiful and suggestive title of a book
published in 2014 by a dutch professor
of psychiatry at boston university
called bessel van der kulk the book has
proved immensely significant because it
emphasizes an idea
that has for too long escaped
psychiatrists and psychotherapists
vander kulk stresses that people who are
suffering emotionally are unlikely to do
so just in their minds
crucially their symptoms almost always
show up in their bodies
in the way they sit or breathe and how
they hold their shoulders
in their sleep patterns in their
digestion processes
in the way they treat their spots and in
their attitude to exercise
taking the body more seriously opens up
new avenues for both the diagnosis
and treatment of emotional unwellness
instead of simply seeing a person as a
disembodied mind
which must talk its way to a cure
a therapist is advised to see the body
as a kind of score sheet
of the emotional experiences that its
owner has been through
a scoresheet that should be read and
attended to as carefully as any mental
account
to take one example many people who have
grown up having to deal with the
overwhelming rage of a parent
will have learnt to suppress their own
anger and their desire to hit back at
those who hurt them
in their minds they will have become
meek and precisely attuned
to fulfilling the wishes of others
however unreasonable these might be
but as importantly in their bodies they
will have learnt to be very
still almost frozen because a part of
them associates the expression of
anything exuberant or powerful
with the risk of bringing about
retaliation from others
these people might sit in a particularly
stiff way or have an ingrained
resistance to running
that has nothing to do with laziness
what is at stake is a fear of one's own
vitality
in trying to treat such people van der
kulk goes beyond advising
traditional talk therapy he would also
recommend that they try
under the supervision of a
therapeutically trained teacher
kickboxing or karate competitive running
or swimming
sports these people might long have
resisted because of a cowed relationship
to their strength
they might also try out rhythmically
chanting or drumming
thereby additionally releasing pent-up
longings to assert one's right to be
traumatized people tend to have bodies
that are either too alert
responding to every breath and touch
flinching and bristling at contact
or else too numb shut down heavy and
immobile
treatment seeks to find a more
comfortable halfway house between these
two extremes vanderkolk's book helps us
to think anew of how to deal with people
who
at the start of their lives were not
properly held
caressed and soothed in the way that
young children desperately need to be
in order to feel at home in their own
skin
as part of their work van der kulk and
his team opened up a sensory integration
clinic in boston
a sort of indoor playground for children
and adults
where one can get back in touch with a
body that was not properly
and by loving hands touched or cuddled
gently swung from side to side or hung
upside down for a giggly moment
in the sensory integration clinic under
the instruction of a therapist
one might dive onto foam-filled mats
have a roll around in a ball pool
jump on a swing and balance on a beam it
sounds
childlike and is meant to be offering a
serious chance to go back a step to
correct a long-standing alienation
those who were once neglected by
emotionally stunted parents
have often almost literally withdrawn
from their bodies
they own them but they do not properly
live in them
they might be rendered deeply
uncomfortable if anyone touches their
shoulders or strokes their back
they might intuitively think their body
was disgusting
because that's how it once seemed in the
eyes of those who were meant to look
after them
for such people vanderkulk might advise
a therapeutically informed massage
to help rebuild a basic trust in one's
skin and limbs
as he puts it he wants the body to have
experiences that deeply and viscerally
contradict the helplessness
rage or collapse that resulted from
trauma
it is no doubt deeply unfortunate that a
difficult past appears to give us
physical as well as mental symptoms
but the body's travails can in
vanderkulk's optimistic account
also become a source of memory and
evidence
when our minds have otherwise seized up
or fatally doubt the legitimacy of their
own feelings
we can start to remember what might have
happened to us
by asking ourselves questions in therapy
and at the same time by taking a look at
how we are sitting
how we breathe and how we feel when
someone we love proposes to hold us
then we can hope to be healed not only
by wise arguments and kind voices
however consoling these might be but
also by dancing
swaying from side to side on a gigantic
swing
chanting in unison or best of all
surrendering ourselves to a very long
and very nourishing hug
from someone we have quietly dared to
trust
how to overcome your childhood is a book
that teaches us how character is
developed
the concept of emotional inheritance the
formation of our concepts of being good
or bad
and the impact of parental styles of
love on the way we choose adult partners